there is a Lost Sea of middle school
kids like a Lost Generation of kids who
the last few years of their elementary
schools in coveted lockdown and it's a
mess I've got a middle schooler I get it
I talk to middle school kids all the
time
it's a mess
but I'm not going to attach all that
mess to my kid
and if I got to pull my kid out of a
school I'm going to pull my kid out of a
school and I'm not going to give my kid
a smartphone
I'm not going to give my kid unfettered
access to bullies 24 7 365 and that
hurts my child I know that it doesn't
hurt them it it makes them uncomfortable
it makes them a pariah it makes them an
outsider I get that
but the data is too clear for me